The warm life I gained when I came to this world
In order to protect it
[Applause] [
Music] I
want to become stronger
[Music] My
only weapon is
HPS, so it doesn't hurt at all, but it's disgusting
[Music] A
weapon for long-range combat  I want it.
HP increased on the first basement floor. On the
second basement floor,
[Music]
Ryota's power increased by 1.
What are you doing?
[Music] What's going on? The drop from
earlier.
This Japanese Nium, which shouldn't drop anything,
dropped S.  I don't want to say that I'm the only one who can raise my status,
but don't
say it yourself.
[Music]
Carrot Night
[Music] is
popular. Is my life in
danger? There's
no carrots here. Let's go to Tellurium quickly. I get it.
Tellurium will come later.  I'll go,
wait for me as a return to the swallow.
[Music]
All I need is a carrot.